let f be a function such that f of
negative 1 is equal to 3 f prime of
negative 1 is equal to 5. let g be the
function g of x is equal to 2x to the
third power
let capital f be a function defined as
so capital f is defined as lowercase f
of x divided by lowercase g of x and
they want us to evaluate the derivative
of capital f at x equals negative one
so the way that we can do that is let's
just take the derivative of capital f
and then evaluate it as at x equals 1.
and the way they've set up capital f
this function definition we can see that
it is the quotient of two functions so
if we want to take its derivative you
might say well maybe the quotient rule
is important here and i'll always give
you my aside the quotient rule i'm going
to state it right now and it could be
useful to know it but in case you ever
forget it you can derive it pretty
quickly from the product rule and if you
know it the chain rule combined you can
get the quotient rule pretty quick but
let me just state the quotient rule
right now
so if you have some function defined as
some function in the numerator divided
by some function in the denominator we
can say its derivative and this is
really just a restatement of the
quotient rule its derivative is going to
be the derivative of the function in the
numerator so d
dx
f of x
times the function in the denominator
so times
g of x
minus
minus the function in the numerator
minus f of x not taking its derivative
times the derivative of the function in
the denominator
d
dx
g
of x
all of that over
so all of this is going to be over the
function and the denominator squared
so this g of x squared g
of x
g of x squared
and you could use multi different types
of notation here you could say you could
instead of writing this with a
derivative operator you could say this
is the same thing as g
prime of x and likewise you could say
well that is the same thing as f prime
of x
and so now we just want to evaluate this
thing and you might say how do i
evaluate this thing well let's just try
it let's just say well let's we want to
evaluate f prime when x is equal to
negative 1. so
we can write
f prime
of negative 1 is equal to well
everywhere we see an x let's put a
negative 1 here
it's going to be f prime of negative 1
f prime lower case f prime is a little
confusing
lower case f prime of negative 1
times
g of negative 1
g
of negative 1
minus
f of
negative 1 f of negative 1 times g prime
of negative 1.
g prime
of negative 1. all of that over
oh let me do that same color
so i take my colors seriously
all right
all of that over
g of negative 1 squared g of negative 1
squared
now can we figure out what f prime of
negative 1 f of negative 1 g of negative
1 and g prime of negative 1 what they
are well some of them they tell us out
right they tell us f and f prime at
negative 1.
and for g we can actually solve for
those so let's see if this is well let's
just first evaluate g of negative 1
g of negative 1 is going to be 2
times negative 1
to the third power well negative 1 to
the third power is just negative 1 times
2 so this is negative 2
and g prime of x i'll do it here g prime
of x which is the power rule bring that
3 out front 3 times 2 is 6
x decrement that exponent 3 minus 1 is
2. and so g prime of negative 1 is equal
to 6
times negative 1 squared well negative 1
squared is just 1 so this is going to be
equal to 6. so we actually know what all
of these values are now
we know so first we want to figure out f
prime of negative 1. well they tell us
that right over here f prime of negative
one is equal to five
so that is five
g of negative one
well we figure that right here g of
negative one is negative two so this is
negative two
f of
negative one let me
so f of negative one they tell us that
right over there
that is equal to three
and then g prime
of negative one let me just
circle it in this green color
g prime of negative one we figured it
out it is equal to six
so this is equal to 6
and then finally g of negative 1 right
over here we already figured that out
that was equal to negative 2. so
negative 2. so this is all going to
simplify to
so you have 5 times negative 2 which is
negative 10
minus 3 times 6 which is 18
all of that over negative 2 squared well
negative 2 squared is just going to be
positive 4. so this is going to be equal
to negative 28 over positive 4 which is
equal to negative 7.
and there you have it it looks
intimidating at first but if you just
say okay look this is i can use the i
can use the quotient rule right over
here and then once i apply the quotient
rule i can actually just directly figure
out what
g of negative 1 g prime of negative 1
and they gave us f of negative 1 and f
prime of negative 1. so hopefully you
find that helpful